there's no such thing as a perfect City
but to me this city is as close as it
comes that's why we're proud to call
Espanola my home oh our home all
right you got it it's
okay this isn't your typical home
flipping show my homes are reflecting
the local community come on I'm we're
husband and wife this is
K so w get go wrong
let's grab a quick shot of you um giving
money to that little girl over there
we're doing good here we are good
people thank you we're really good got
it so all I had on me was that $100 bill
no refund that's not fair come on let me
go get change and what is that that's
nothing this is you don't need to see
this why did you snatch back the money
why didn't you just give her the 100 I
was going to buy six of them for $20 I
curse you
what did she say i
p
what what things have been a little
weird I just need some this thing that
you're doing right now it's helping the
community it's immune to
criticism hi oh margorie can speak to
the work much better than I can I think
I'll let the work speak for
itself
[Music]
just cuz Whitney has a moral issue with
something that's happening we just toss
it
away this doesn't make
sense hi um is everything
okay maybe this is all happening for a
reason I can't wait for this show to
come
[Music]
about everyone will get to see who you
really are
[Music]
you you know you can tell me anything
right of
[Music]
course